and the moment for me last night was
when bud dupree forced the fumble on
andy dalton in the first half t.j watt
recovered it that was when
i said
why did i think the bengals were going
to win this game yes uh and and yeah and
and it was just relentless all night and
peter in the second half and booger
mcfarlane pointed this out you're down
21 points
and
there's no sense of urgency there's no
sense of fight in the bengals and you
can hide a lackluster performance in a
cluster of 1 pm eastern games on a
sunday but when you're in prime time and
the cameras are everywhere and they see
the look on your face and andy dalton
just had that look of i really don't
want to be here anymore
it's it's that's a horrible look for the
bengals and it suggests they're going to
lose a lot more games this year
i mean you know what i found myself
thinking last night mike
i said to myself
if you're to a tag of aloha or if you're
justin herbert
you have to be watching that game
and say
oh my god
please pick me first dolphins
because you know what's gonna happen
you know what's gonna happen the bengals
are gonna have the second pick in the
draft
and there's going to be an outcry and i
think justifiably so to take andy
dalton's successor there's nothing wrong
with andy dalton to me he's a nice
24th 28th quarterback in the league but
it's like year after year you go along
with andy dalton it's like what the
giants did with eli manning are you
competitive yes do you win some games
yes are you a championship team no
you're not and i realize they have no
line and they don't have aj green and i
don't want to be unfair right andy
dalton all i'm saying all i'm saying
is that the cincinnati bengals are going
to have the second pick in a quarterback
rich draft
and when they have that pick there's
likely to be two players and who knows
maybe there will be other guys because
every year it changes between october
and april so who knows but all i'm
saying is i hope for any kid's sake that
he doesn't get sentenced to play at
cincinnati it it's scary it's going that
way i mean uh
you know we mike and i did a draft last
thursday right the hot seat draft andy
dalton was one of my picks because you
know again you're right he's not the
reason you blame here he's not like the
culprit number one in this situation
peter to what you're saying there's a
lot of issues around him but at the same
time i think we've seen enough from andy
dalton to go he's not the franchise guy
and at some point they're gonna have to
move on i wouldn't be shocked if it
happened this year the kid they drafted
in the chris the fourth round ryan
finley was phenomenal in the preseason i
mean i think they might give him a shot
before all said and done sorry peter go
ahead
i would just i would just ask you this
one question yeah if you were if you
were the if you were just an absolute
person on the sidelines just watching
the games and just basically
and you got confronted with this
question
if i gave you the opportunity to have
one of the following two guys on your
roster today who would you take would
you take andy dalton or would you take
gardner minshew
and i'm not even saying your take
gardener minchu to be the quarterback
for the next 15 years right i'm just
saying right now yeah to play a game
next sunday right who would you rather
have play a game
that's that's my point that's my point
about andy dalton yeah i don't think
it's fair peter i mean we don't see me
and mike talked about it right we don't
see fire we don't see leadership from
andy dalton things are going bad i mean
i saw him throw the ball away once like
he was mad about the pass protection but
at some point somebody's got to give a
patrick mahomes type speech on the
sideline right that we just saw in the
opening on on the tv side or or a tom
brady like you know let's go what the
hell are we doing out here you know i
mean at some point somebody's got to do
that uh and yes uh there's just seems to
be a lack of moxie or leadership that
way from andy dalton i don't want to sit
here and blame him all the way but to
your point yes gardner the minsu ginsu
is uh has a little bit of that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports